sequels are a big business in Hollywood
and every studio loves the franchise
still sometimes a movie just can't pass
that initial bar of quality that gets a
sequel greenlit in the first place
filmmakers might have grand plans for a
franchise only to have them sorted
before they can get started because of
lousy reviews and low box-office
receipts here are some plans sequels
that were completely abandoned Superman
Returns again Bryan Singer's Superman
sequel from 2006 was kind of a bad idea
from the start it followed up the events
of Superman to ignored Superman three
and four and two of its major plot
points revolves around Superman super
stalking his former girlfriend Lois Lane
as well as a revelation that her son was
their secret love child
worst of all the movie didn't really
give Superman very much to do in terms
of actually fighting bad guys which you
know is one of the things Superman does
that Warner Brothers pulled the plug on
the possibility of another singer helm
sequels while screenwriter Michael
Dougherty says he might have introduced
Brainiac and more Kryptonians to the
screen identified try asking nice
Kryptonian Batman triumphant George
Clooney's first outing as the Caped
Crusader in 1997 Batman and Robin was
not supposed to be his last
in fact Warner Brothers was gearing up
to bring back Clooney and co-stars Chris
O'Donnell and Alicia Silverstone for a
sequel titled Batman triumphant which
would have been directed by Joel
Schumacher
however Batman and Robin was a critical
joke summoning more laughs than it's
campy Crypt ever intended audiences who
flocked to watch Val Kilmer in the
Batsuit just two years before simply
didn't show up to see what uma thurman
poison ivy and Arnold Schwarzenegger Mr
Freeze would be adding to the villainous
fold this go-round foiler alert they
didn't miss much except for a few
terrible puns what killed the dinosaurs
my name is trees and well
good time if Batman triumphant had
happened as planned it reportedly would
have relied on the Scarecrow and Harley
Quinn as the Joker's daughter to slay
the bad guys and they would have been
joined by fear gas induce appearances
from the Joker penguin Catwoman
new face and the Riddler in an effort to
get Bruce Wayne committed to Arkham
Asylum dregg - this is probably the most
tragic entry on the list since the first
read starring Karl Urban is a
legitimately amazing movie unfortunately
it seems that the stink of Sylvester
Stallone's 1995 Judge Dredd adaptation
was too strong for moviegoers to ignore
and Dredd failed to find an audience
during its theatrical run it's a cult
hit though so there's still an outside
chance Dredd - could happen before we
all get old and die in fact in early
2017 producer Adi Shankar vowed to make
some sort of follow-up happen even if
it's animated each old Collider close
I'm going to make it happen at some
point it may not be a live action but
it's going to happen at some point there
will be more Judge Dredd at some point
Fantastic Four 3 the first cinematic
outing from 20th Century Fox's
adaptation of Marvel's first family
wasn't great but it did well enough to
spawn a sequel 2007 rise of the Silver
Surfer this one was actually a bit
better featuring a version of Galactus
and the power cosmic but it still wasn't
good enough by a long shot the franchise
ground to a screeching halt after it
underperformed at the box office and as
star Chris Evans later told MTV no one
from the cast ever even got a call from
Fox about coming back for more just goes
to show you that signing a three-picture
deal doesn't mean as much as you might
hope oh my god
Green Lantern to the original 2011 Ryan
Reynolds vehicle was supposed to
kickstart a whole DC superhero franchise
to rival Marvel's ever-expanding
Cinematic Universe
DC's corporate parent Warner Brothers
set big on Green Lantern sending a
whopping 200 million dollars on the
movie and it only barely turned a profit
between the film's cliffhangers and its
efforts to build a big world for Green
Lantern to play in the movie was
considered a failure and all plans for a
sequel were scrapped
Green Lantern said to be rebooted to fit
in with the DC extended universe
presumably at least the studio hope for
the final time the Mortal Instruments
city of ashes by all estimations the
adaptation of Cassandra Clare's young
adult sensation series The Mortal
Instruments seemed like it be the next
big hit in the vein of Twilight and The
Hunger Games
it had all the essential ingredients
including a huge book loving fanbase
that clung to every moment of the
production phase and cast members who
engaged in an off-screen romance Samira
their screen counterparts
so naturally 2013's The Mortal
Instruments City of Bones was expected
to launch an entire franchise that would
have capitalized on the craze
surrounding a sister series the script
for city of ashes had already been drawn
up and the actors and crew already had a
production schedule in place before the
results of the first film's release came
through and puts the brakes on
everything it wasn't the early critical
blast that stymie the sequel don't
forget scathing reviewers sung The
Twilight Saga - it was the fact that the
much-hyped film grossly disappointed at
the box office making just half of its
production budget back in domestic sales
and according to Cassandra Clare herself
the sequel to ashes would have been
unrecognizable - the book series
faithful thus weakening audience
interest even further ultimately despite
some early signs that the second Mortal
Instruments tick might be retooled and
eventually made the project was
abandoned and the series was instead
relegated to the small screen by way of
freeform Shadowhunters so it wasn't a
total wash twins - triplets twins was
something of a high concept comedy that
revolves entirely around a single sight
gag muscle Laden Austrian Superman
Arnold Schwarzenegger and teeny-tiny
Brooklynite Danny DeVito play long-lost
twin the 1988 hit directed by
Ghostbusters mastermind Ivan Reitman was
a breezy romp in which the two stars
hung out and goofed off under the
auspices of their characters getting to
know each other who are you
Vincent's brother twins and because
twins was such a hit rumours hit almost
immediately after its release that a
sequel was coming in 1989 a
representative for reitman said that the
director was considering making a movie
called wait for it
triplets
top candy display the third long-lost
multiple didn't look anything like the
others which was essential of course and
was the hottest comedy star of the
moment Roseanne Barr that movie never
got made of course but in 2012 there was
renewed talk of triplets without bar but
with Eddie Murphy but considering how
many years have passed with no more news
on that front triplets is probably not
going to happen so don't start this
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]